well hello I'm Greg I'm Nina Anita from
Anita stargazer Channel where the stars
are always gazing from the haze of the
marijuana phase how Star Wars wrote one
should have ended should have ended what
Anita has never seen how it should've
ended seen a lot of things at my damn
shame you haven't seen how it should
have ended because they are one of the
best channels ever on YouTube oh yeah
yeah well with the almost 7 million subs
I'd say so
the numbers mean everything
[Music]
[Music]
I'm like why quite okay sir we've
arrived at her so far excellent would
now circle around cooking time and then
last extremely far far away sir
yes nice $400 hello walk in a straight
line it will look for paper what am i
given I know it will be intimidated and
everyone is going to love it
what did you say nobody can understand
you guys for real you don't have to
scramble your word all the time okay
fine we'll land right at that doorstep
geez why don't you take the objectors
out of every well okay you'll need a
structural plan Vanessa and I know
there's a data archive of girl but that
would be a total suicide mission and I
never sent my daughter arms way to
exchange ideas coming to plunge to a
disk and it will flicker pilot body
but albums Bodi oh yes the pilot he was
carrying these flat your father was a
wise man take your message kid yes bhai
oh my god careful Vicky thank you so
much
no problem now have a good trip this
case in the impending tidal wave of
death ah you know coming with us
are you I'm still in command
I built you a desktop and this gives you
to be careful not to choke on your
aspirations to record action really -
what do you mean why do you say that do
you think I'm a father
no no later it's just what you said what
they call a dad joke mm-hmm like a bad
pun oh not a father how unfortunate
because if I was a father
I beat there
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
congratulations you are being rescued
okay are you serious you were about to
make out with her even though she's
before you he relies a Tokoloshe chances
for survival under 30% this is why I'd
reactively copied my memory banks into
that other joint we have earlier da well
this really smart case and we're all
still alive - you're not literally
humping it
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
something about you talking you lose
weight no a new haircut
perhaps no that's not it
oh you know what it's the digital place
[Music]
honey
hey Lord thanks so much for watching we
hope you enjoyed it and a special thanks
goes to audible for making this episode
possible audible great getting on it I'm
working on my art with my eyes in my
hands but my ears are just left creating
for anybody hmm maybe I'll check out
some Star Wars lore lots to choose from
if you don't know what audible is they
have an unmatched collection of
audiobook and they are offering how much
should a minute viewers like yourself a
free book your choice with a 30 day
trial membership just go to audible.com
unikz done a lot of audio well Anita
what did you think I thought it was
awesome I mean what I didn't know this
was a thing now I have to write and
visualize and there's billions yeah that
was amazing I like that there was no
title scroll in road one I didn't you
didn't know well the funny joke here I
made for a fine make for a funny joke
yeah the truth of the matter when I went
into and I was just like I felt like
something was missing because there is
no title Scully oh sorry go that way I
was appreciative of it I'm like this is
not part of the Skywalker saga yeah okay
that it's done Renee anything I can
season we need a title crawl for every
one of these do for every one of them I
always loved it like little jokes on
weird touches that certain movies have
like the joke at the beginning about sir
playing around twice and letting water
because that is no comment yeah what is
that even about I liked the joke at the
end too about the digital face thing and
I knew that they were gonna go for when
he was like something different about me
because it really
is noticeable yes right now I mean he
want it not to be but I know it just
it's like he can't if something just
doesn't look right
yeah I wasn't even aware that that actor
had died watching it I'm like no no
space yeah why are they trying to make a
me younger yeah is he dead
I think the most awful that I've ever
seen with those digital faces is
Twilight when they did the little girl
like Renesmee I think yeah oh my god I
was so terribly took me out of the
moment completely I couldn't focus on
like the story I was like it's just so
bad when June's father dies that thing
yeah I thought that was really funny cuz
I'm like make you a save it I didn't
know and I was wondering the same and I
love how nonchalant she was this weird
all right [ __ ] it happily oh my god meet
me look your favorite Star Wars
characters
oh I pops up between Jar Jar and Hayden
Christensen's Anakin's gun oh well of
course those are the two best options
oh really sad we're not gonna see them
again my legitimate favorite character
is Darth Vader and so when I saw him in
rogue one I was just like oh and then he
was just such a badass I really wanted
them to take it to a matrix place where
he's like using the force of a laser
beam just stop anything around and super
fun yeah that's cool as that actions
weren't in a movie it was like you could
have got it yeah I think it could have
gotten really funny man I don't know I
mean big did an awesome job don't get me
wrong but I see I'm still like yeah you
could have gotten you guys could hear
the neatest joke you could you could
have used in men Donnie Yen turned his
dick into a lifesaver not a drat that
would have been cool no that is cool
touch they actually happen in here wish
that that happened in the movie though
randomly comes out of the lake spirit
and I'm glad they all died I am too I
like that Heidi I mean it could have
felt like like watching this how it
should have ended with you know how kay
to us so copy himself into another droid
yeah that does make sense that's in our
Wars world that could have happened
absolutely the other campaign time
though I feel like that wouldn't have
liked that if it actually happened that
way I wouldn't I wanted them to live
well not all of them but just the truth
that make sense yeah yeah I mean anyone
could have lived I probably would have
gone with the droid
that of all of that would have been
awesome like maybe he'll come back yeah
because the droid is the one character
Rome like it would make sense why we
haven't seen him in them he has balm
exact I would love to see that character
again because honestly that was one of
my favorite characters the best if not
my favorite yeah it's the best ROI that
or anyone you think alright guys well
subscribe to how it should have ended
how we gonna then drive to the real
rejects subscribe to the real news
stargazers on the Stargazer of the
channels like that I gave on the cars
and are easing off the weed well that's
right lots of marijuana and shout out to
George Lucas George Lucas I'm shut out
sorry no one likes you anymore
may the force be with you